who are the economic hitmen
are they putting insolvent countries in
huge debt in order to control them
and profit from their resources
the rich were getting rich but the poor
were getting poorer
i think what's important is that it
absolutely happened and it benefited a
small group of rich people in the global
north
that it's important for people to
understand this is a systemic problem
has crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
money was being diverted from health
care education uh to pay off the loans
there were a lot of people that did
benefit from these crises everything has
been done
to keep this game going
are there economic hitmen from powerful
organizations
that get poor countries to sign up for
infrastructures that they don't
necessarily need
and take up loans that they essentially
cannot repay
in order to make profit
after i studied economics i worked as a
stock trader
i traded stocks and bonds for a few
years
i would read company research and study
the price movement in the market
it sounds boring but i loved it
i actually still do
in my family everyone is good with
numbers
but i left the trading floor to become
an actor
and because of my previous job in the
market i came across a book titled
confessions of an economic hitman by
john perkins and i was shocked
these people were not discussing buying
and selling stocks or companies
it is actually about buying and selling
entire economies
the writer talked about economic hitmen
who coordinate with bigger nations to
exploit and devour poorer countries
professional people whose job is to
deceive countries and extort them with
trillions of dollars
[Music]
is this a colonial tactic
to strip countries of their resources
and political will
a country that needs to build or renew
its infrastructure
we'll need capital
it also needs the expertise technology
equipment and all of that
developing countries likely will import
some or all of this
from another country
in order to pay for the imports they
will take a loan
it seems simple and straightforward
right
fortunately i can talk to someone who
did this job
his name is john perkins
i want to ask him about his previous job
i was recruited by a big international
consulting firm called charles d maine
which which has been since been bought
so the name no longer is out there my
title was chief economist
and i had as many as 50 people working
for me my job really was to identify
countries that had resources our
corporations wanted like oil like in the
middle east oil and then to arrange for
a huge loan
to that country from the world bank or
the imf or one of the sister
organizations
but the money would not actually go to
the country itself the country would
collateralize the loan
with its
resource
but the money would go directly to our
own corporations big engineering
companies like bechdel and halliburton
and brown and rude and my own company
would get a piece of the action to build
infrastructure projects in the country
things like power plants and industrial
parks and highways things that benefited
a few rich people in those countries as
well as making huge profits for our own
corporations
[Music]
a long time i thought i was doing the
right thing as many people in that
business do
but over time i began to see that those
those statistics gdp gross domestic
product and other statistics are very
skewed to the rich and so the rich were
getting rich but the poor were getting
poorer because
money was being diverted from health
care education and other social services
and just basic foods and supplies
to pay off the loans i should mention
one other thing
that
these presidents of these countries knew
that if they accepted the loans they
were putting their countries deep into
debt
but they were also they were going to
get wealthy off this their families were
going to benefit because they owned the
businesses they owned the industries
they are the things that were helped by
electricity and so forth but there was
another incentive for them and that was
that
what we call shackles were in the
background and these are cia assets
usually
who overthrow governments or assassinate
their leaders
john perkins is not the only one that
spoke about this
many others say that developing
countries which are in heavy debt
may go through coups and assassinations
as a result of not wanting to play by
these rules
and they say that these institutions and
companies that lend countries have
thousands of employees
and some jobs there are to manufacture
and manage such crises
i reached vincent bevin's author of the
jakarta method a book which discusses
the american intervention and collusion
during the mass killings of indonesians
by their government in the 60s i am sure
he has something to say about this
hi vincent are there
figures like economic hitmen really
ones that force abusive contracts on
nations and countries
what i can say is that in the second
half of the 20th centuries it was
absolutely true that a lot of countries
in the global south countries that used
to be part of something called the third
world movement ended up saddled with a
lot of debt which became unsustainable
and the fact that they were saddled with
debt and the fact that the debt became
unsustainable has still has a lot to do
with institutions and actors um based in
the global north so are these
institutions and actors from the north
economic hitmen who is benefiting from
this there were a lot of people that did
benefit from these crises whether or not
they were
financial actors or key players in
international banks i think what's
important is that it absolutely happened
and it benefited a small group of rich
people in the global north and do you
think that
these practices are still in place today
it's now fairly well recognized that the
prescriptions the imf uh was going
around the world and handing out to
indebted in poor countries were often
very destructive the imf has even gone
back on a lot of what it said in the
past was the right medicine for a
country that quote-unquote had problems
uh even if those problems might have
been generated by the the system itself
but at the time nobody was questioning
this and the fact that the imf 20 30
years later says oops uh well you know
we actually might have ruined uh half
the world's countries doesn't change the
fact that we're still on the path today
that was created by those actions
generations ago
from an economic perspective and even
capitalistic one wouldn't you say that
keeping everybody
healthy
with good purchase power to engage in
the global economy
is better for the whole world
than crippling them by loans that they
cannot repay this is the paradox at the
i think the heart of liberal ideology
right because one would believe based on
the tenets of economics um practiced in
the english-speaking world and one would
believe based on the ideals of
liberalism in general that it would be
better for everyone to make sure
the countries in the global south are
growing just as fast and as robustly as
any other country but what we have seen
is that did not happen over the last 70
years and countries in the global north
are still doing just fine
[Music]
in the middle of so much data
someone could say well these countries
and regimes
accepted the deal and committed
willingly
nobody forced them
i will ask this question to the american
economist richard dewolfe
hi professor wolf how are you very good
i'm very glad to be here what can you
tell me about the so-called economic
hitmen and corporations or institutions
that strangle countries economies first
of all it happens all the time
it is nothing new
it is not rare it is common so somebody
from a powerful corporation goes and
will sometimes connect to a local
equivalent of himself
and cut a deal and say look
i'm going to get paid 10 million dollars
for getting this done
i will give you two million dollars if
you become my local eyes and ears to
help me work this out forgive me if i
will sound naive isn't the country
receiving this loan participating
willingly in this terrible deal happens
all the time people from third world
countries can get into that because they
understand this game and they get the
job because they say i know better about
the details of local politics and by the
way it often fails
don't imagine it's all so smooth
sometimes one of these people will get
drunk and say the wrong thing to the
wrong person sometimes a local official
will have a change of heart and want out
of this situation
sometimes people who take a fortune then
get blackmailed by somebody else who
knows they did that and now they have to
get out of that
international credit is a very
complicated sneaky personal business
that can have all the different twists
and turns that you can imagine
sometimes we have whistleblowers people
who speak up out of principle
this could change things actually right
the only answer i can give you is
that
everything has been done
imaginable
to keep this game going and one of the
most important
things is that when you get caught
either nothing is done or one or two
individuals are punished
but you never
change the basic system and let me be
for a moment the advocate of the banker
who initiates this
that banker knows
that if he can work three or four big
deals
one in ecuador one in mali and one in
malaysia he will be promoted to the
president of the bank that's how you
succeed in the bank they don't care how
you do it you shouldn't embarrass the
bank of course but your job is to get
that loan done
so if you don't because you are honest
or you have scruples
you are shooting yourself in the foot
you are
destroying your own career so often you
will if you know these people they will
tell you
they have
no
choice
but it's important for people to
understand
this is a systemic problem
[Music]
[Music]
after i left my job as a trader i
started a career in acting
and there were times when i didn't know
when the next check will be coming
i understand how it is to be in a
difficult financial situation and how
this makes you vulnerable
imagine when the entire economy of a
state is placed on the betting table
this can put them in a vulnerable
position
unable to negotiate anything but their
survival
i know some questions are painful to ask
but i still will ask them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you